hello i'm yong guli a former
postdoctoral researcher in dr marco vela
lab
today on behalf of dr marco vella lab
i'm going to introduce interesting study
where
dr vella conducted to understand the
resistance mechanism of the car t-cell
therapy
as many of you know well the chimery
anticipation receptor t-cell therapy is
a new form of immunotherapy that
includes the genetic engineering of
patient t-cell to redirect them against
the cancer
anti-city 19 car t cell have been
particularly successful against the
piece of leukemia and lymphoma with the
first car t19 product to be approved
by the fda being developed at
japan
now we have multiple fda approved
car t cell as shown here
for various indication including diesel
leukemia lymphoma and multiple myeloma
as mentioned earlier the cartesian
therapy have achieved great success in
targeting the basal leukemia and
lymphoma
briefly the 80 of leukemia patients
showed a complete remission rate
and
around fifty percent of lymphoma
patients have achieved a complete
remission rate after carte 19 treatment
despite this great antitumor efficacy
not all patients have same experience
as shown here the more than
50 percent of leukemia and lymphoma
patients still
show no response or some response
initially
but eventually tumor is relapsed
this clinical research strongly
indicates that it is essential to
develop a nobel effective approach that
can improve the car t cells and titanium
efficacy so we could help patients who
currently have no other clinical options
but in order to help in order to develop
the most
potent car t cell therapy the first
thing that we need to do is to
understand
uh the resistance mechanisms that
drive the failure of the car t cells uh
therapy
as you may know there are mortiful
factors that can affect car t cells and
titanium activity for example
immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment
including mdsc
tom t-rex could reduce the cartilage and
titanium activity by secreting the
various immunosuppressive cytokines
in addition to these intrinsic extrinsic
factors tumor itself could also
generate a vertical resistant mechanism
to car t cell therapy by modulating
their molecular features such as the
expression level of the inhibitory
receptor on their surface surf a surface
despite multiple study found the
importance biological factors that can
reduce the car t cells and titanium
activity
it may be quite difficult to identify
the most important
molecular features in cancer that
dominantly
led to lead to the failure of the
cartesian therapy
since the design of most previous study
was mainly focused on the specific
the molecular pathway based on their
interest
so to overcome this problem dr nathan
singh in dr mark rivera lab performed
very interesting research
in this study they hypothetized that the
most important tumor intrinsic factor
that can affect the car t cells and
tattoo activity can be identified by
functional genomics approach
using the genome-wide crispr knockout
screening platform
before introducing the data let me
briefly go over the protocol of the
study
in this genome-wide crispr naka
screening
they used a
pool of land divider
crispr libraries named brunello
libraries that use the
con that use
they target the 20 000 uh different
genes
by 76 000 different single guide rna
with this length divider
vector containing of each guide rna and
cas9 they generate the lengthy virus
and then they transduce their uh this
lengthy virus into the bethel leukemia
cells called numsex
and
they select the transduced cell by using
the pillow myosin
after selecting the transduce num 6 they
could culture them with the cartien19
and harvest to survive the non-six
to identify what tumor intrinsic factor
affect the car t-cells and titanium
activity
by performing the next generation
sequencing
with this protocol they
identify the various interesting wizard
and today i'm going to introduce some
key research
first they found that the number six
with the knockout of positive regulators
of extrinsic apoptosis such as caspase-8
fat and beet
and des receptor 5
survived much better in the presence of
the cartoon 19 than the one that had
knockout of the
negative regulator of the extrinsic
hypothesis including burke
c flip
traf2 in addition the genset in niche
mental analysis also demonstrate that
the apoptosis was the most innate
pathway
and this results strongly suggests that
the modulation of apoptosis especially
in gas receptor mediated in extrinsic
hypothesis in cancer may have
substantial impact on the sensitivity of
cancer cell to cartesian-mediated kiln
uh for those of who are not familiar
with apoptosis let me briefly introduce
the general idea of the hypothesis
hypothesis can be classified into two
pathway such as intrinsic pathway and in
extrinsic epiphany pathway
first intrinsic epithelial pathway can
be triggered by factors like
chemotherapy radiation dna damage
and this intrinsic hypothesis is
strongly associated with mitochondrial
mediated apoptosis
for instance when the intrinsic popular
pathway is triggered the bh3 only
protein like the bam
bead bad inhibit the function of the
bcl-2 which is the key entire factory
regulator of intrinsic popular pathway
upon inhibition of dcl2 backs
form homodimer and destabilize the
membrane of mitochondria as a result
pro-eptoric molecules such as cytochrome
c is released
and they initiate hypothesis
on the other hand
extrinsic apoptosis can be triggered
when gas receptor ligand such as vest
ligand tnfr pod trail
interact with their associated receptor
like fast tnf receptor and trade
receptor
upon binding of the death ligands to
their associated receptor uh the pro
effectory regulator like a fed
uh and caspase-a are formed that's
inducing signaling complex
to promote the downstream of the
apoptotic signal pathway
however to inhibit this extrinsic
factory pathway anti-apartheid
molecules such as flip ciap
and tra
af2 plays an important role as i
introduced in previous study
and
as i introduced in previous study the uh
nathan found that the cancer cell become
more resistant to cartile therapy when
caspase of
when cast paste
uh
aid were when fair then caspase 8 were
not gone on the other hand the lack of
entire factory molecules such as the
ciap
safely and traf2 induce the
cartesian-mediated tumor kiln
so to validate their genome-wide crispr
screening nathan generate the fed and
beat knuckle
abisal leukemia cells and study whether
this effectory resistant cancer cell can
reduce the car t-cells anti-tumor
activity
as shown here the fat and the beet
knuckle dramatically reduce the car
t-cell's anti-tumor activity in vitro
and in vivo
suggesting that the modulation of
apoptosis sensitivity in cancer cell can
affect the car t cell's anti-tumor
activity
to identify the molecular program's
response for the card-driven t-cell
dysfunction they perform the
transcriptomic
and epigenomic investigation of the car
t cell exposed to
y-type and beat knockout number six
in the analysis of the gene expression
profiles of the car t cell at rest were
after 15 days of the chronic exposure to
wild type orbit knockout number six
cells
they identified
around
1200
express the genes
more specifically cartilage cells are
exposed to the bead knockout non-6 cells
demonstrate increased expression of the
known dysfunction
associate genes such as the egr2 ctla4
and irf4 btla tox2 and nr4a2
in addition they also identify the
decreased expression of the t-cell
activating genes including t-cell
signaling molecules such as slam
slam f6 lck jak-1
and s-o-s-1
stimul and moreover a stimulated
stimulatory surface receptor and
transcriptional activators
in addition the study the carti
uh they also study uh the cartes 19
chromatomas chromatin accessibility to
determine if persistence and
antigen exposure result in epigenetic
imprinting associated with the
dysfunction
similar with the rna sequencing data
they found that they enhance the
promoter accessibility of several key
inner suppressive
transcription factors
such as tox2
irfp
irf8 and prdm1
uh embed knockout uh exposed to car t19
so together
this finding suggests that the
persistent exposure to apoptosis
resistant leukemia lead to the global uh
problematic uh change in cartilage cells
that are similar with the t-cell
exhaustion which eventually lead to the
failure of the the car t cells
therapeutic
effect
finally they confirmed their preclinical
research by evaluating the clinical
samples
to this end they evaluate the expression
of
a group of genes that plays the key role
in inducing
gas receptor mediated hypothesis in the
leukemia cell
from ball patient
who
treated with a carti19
upon the expression level of the
positive regulators in that
receptor-mediated apoptosis they then
divide the patient into two different
groups first high score group
where the patients have a higher
expression level of the positive
regulators of this receptor mediated
hypothesis
second low score group
which have the lower expression of these
positive regulators
and very interestingly as shown here
but they've they found
that the uh the patient with the high
score
all house high score meaning the high
level of positive regulator of this
receptor showed a significant higher
overall survival rate as compared to
the lower group
so this data clearly support that the
sensitivity of apoptosis particularly
that's receptor-mediated apoptosis in
cancer have substantial impact on the
car t cells anti-tumor activity
so in addition to the in tumor intrinsic
factors that caused the failure of the
car t cell therapy uh dr ruela found
also found a very interesting car t
intrinsic factors that significantly
impact on the car t cells and titanium
activity
so as a second part of the talk i'm
going to introduce the
another study where dr vella studied how
the car t cell signaling
driven by the car t cell structure of
factor car t-cells anti-tumor activity
uh while dr voller group conducted two
pilot critical trials to test
efficacy of the city 22 targeting car t
cell in patients with relaxed or
refractory leukemia
they observed unexpectedly low response
rate in the trials as compared to with
uh
with compared to the previous clinical
outcome of the city 22 targeting car t
cell
developed by the nci
while the direct comparison of distinct
clinical trials at different
institutions is
inherently limited
the differing the outcomes of these two
trials of cardi 22 between nci and the
upan were striking
uh basically uh the pen
uh clinical outcome in the pan clinical
outcome uh
dr ruela observed the 50
the complete remission rate
where the nci trials
they achieved a 73 the cr rate
and these different clinical results
actually led to the explorer the
potential factor that may affect the
car 22 anti-tumor efficacy
to understand the difference
they investigate motif factors
for instance the patient characteristic
and manufacturing process in these
dryers were uh were quite similar
and both car constructs were composed of
the uh m971
which is the name clone name of the car
22
uh sfb
as well as the uh
same hinge and transmembrane and
tri-cellular signaling domains
they eventually identified that these
two constructs
used
in pan and nci differed only in the
lengths of the scfb linker as shown here
the cd22 car evaluated by nci
connected heavy to light chain using a
gggs amino acid linker just the one gggs
linker
while the triers of the university of
pennsylvania connected the variable
chains using the four times lipid of the
gggs
so which means that it has much longer
linker between the habit to light chain
therefore based on this difference they
hypothesize that the sfp linker length
may influence
car t cells and titan activity
so to validate their hypothesis they
first generate the cartesian with either
a short or long scfb linker
and perform the head-to-head comparison
in the preclinical setting to see
whether the difference of the linker
length
actually impact over cartesian
anti-tumor efficacy as we
saw in the clinical outcome
so as shown here
uh the prolonged in vitro co-culture
we build the superior cytotoxicity of
the cartilage 22
short t cells
they contain the uh much short linker as
compared to the one with the longer
linker
and collection of the cool cultures
pronatant was also demonstrated that the
higher secretion of pro-inflammatory
cytokines such as interferon gamma il-2
and tnf-r-pop
by the car 22
uh
sure uh t cell which is labeled as the
uh the green
so next they also evaluate
the in vivo activity of the
car 22 which contains either sure or
long linker
in the immunodeficient nsg mice bearing
the
b cell
acute lipoblastic leukemia
so car 22 short t cell as shown here
demonstrates a significant enhanced
disease control
while the car 22
with longer recurve
only partially reduce the disease burden
compared to the
control t cell
this difference were also
reflected by the invisible t cell
expansion as you can see here
and directly translate to the enhanced
the
animal survivor
so this in vitro and in vivo data
confirmed that the
the short linker could dramatically
affect the car t cells and diatomic
activity
so to understand the molecular mechanism
how the sfp linker
length influenced the car t cells and
titanium activity
they perform they first perform the
biochemical evaluation
measurement of the scfp
as shown here revealed a no significant
difference between short and long
linkers
interestingly predictive uh protein
structure as shown here
uh
modeling of two uh scfp suggests that
the longer linker allowed appropriate
the pairing
of the heavy and
light chain
from the same molecule why the show
linker inhibit the
intramolecular heavy and light chain
pairing
uh this modeling is consistent with the
previous sfp study demonstrating that
linkers is uh more than nine
amino acid in length allowed appropriate
sfp folding however the linkers shorter
than nine amino exits in length are
known to induce the uh rigid sfp
structure that prohibits the
intramolecular
the variable chain pairing and instead
they promote the intermolecular heavy
and light chain pairing
which often result in the small increase
in measured
binding affinity as shown
as we can see in our construct
evaluation of the sfp
[Music]
oligomerization using the size uh
exclusive chromatography confirmed that
the car 22 long uh exists as a monomer
uh while the
um
why the car 22 short are homodymerized
to better understand how slp
dimerization impact activity of the car
molecules we engineered t cell to
express the gfp as shown here
in a frame with a car a polypeptide
allowing us to visualize the receptor
distribution on the cell surface using
confocal microscopy
car 22 law distribute low uh uniformity
across the cell surface as shown here
while the car 22 short appeared to
self-aggregate and cluster
and based on this observation we
hypothesized that the short linker
promote the clustering of her
leading to then antigen independent t
cell activation
and this antigen-independent t-cell
activation eventually results in
enhancement of the car t cells and
titanium activity by prime
priming the cartisol to activation
to understand the impact of the car
clustering on antigen-independent
receptor activity they evaluate the
difference in signaling protein
activation
driven by long and short
receptor in the absence of target
antigen
by using the
phosphor peptide array 28.
the car cholesterol exerted in the
greater phosphorylation of
critical t-cell signaling molecules in
pi3k
and meta-kinase pathways
they also observe the increased
activation of ppc3 a key cell cycle
regulators protein
they also next investigate the
transcriptional
impact of this
observed difference in tonic signaling
the gene said management analysis
revealed a significant increase in
expression of cell cycle
programs
so together with the previous data this
data strongly suggests that the car
clustering results in
antigen-independent t-cell activation
leading to increase of the car t-cells
anti-tumor efficacy
so in conclusion the uh
doctor mark varela identified that the
acquired the resistance to apoptosis in
cancer is a key feature that could
contribute to the failure of the
cartesian therapy
and on by an unbiased genome-wide low
cell function screen
they identify the critical importance of
the death receptor signaling in tumor
cells on car t-cell cytotoxic functions
in addition
they also identify the shortening the
amino acid linker connected
connecting
variable heavy and light chains of car
antigen binding domain
drive receptor homodimerization
and antigen independent signaling
and in contrast to the cd28 based car
the autonomously signaling
forum bb based cars demonstrate enhanced
immune synapse formation
and activation of pro-inflammatory genes
and superior
effector function
here are my acknowledgements i think i
thank all
who
were involved in this great study and
especially i really appreciate dr mark
weller and dr june and dr gill for their
kind support
in addition i would like to thank my
foreign source whose uh which support my
uh
research and thank you for your
attention